nous allons faire une petit bateau en un
contre un de wine alors sonia c'est toi
qui me l'a demandé personnellement de
quoi je voudrais que tu commences
d'accord sonia tu vas déjà affrontés en
citant même quoi tu vas affronter tiffen
je suis sûr qu'elle passe on y achète et
qu'on va aller
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors celui déjà je vous dis petit fanni
[Applaudissements]
à la fin c'est pas toujours ainsi quand
tu arrives en boîte on chez bret santé
fondée
paris
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce
[Musique]
françois lacôte oslo d'inquiétude on s'y
perd bientôt quoi il pouvait pas
regarder les beatles c'est quoi je ne
voulais pas regarder parce que sonia t
comme ma soeur mais c'est vrai on
s'épaule élire la femme chocolat devient
des années 20 mise au nez à et moi et je
peux vous dire j'ai dit non tu vois ça
auront lieu de dire c'est donc ça on
pense que les papillons se connaît
depuis très longtemps secret longtemps
on s'adore mois la jouer j'adore se
tenir et d'ailleurs j'ai rencontré de la
fois au restaurant
oui et voilà où est il m'a dit tu
m'appelles fait appeler bachar
[Rires]